maskierte menschen auf den straßen wenig
touristen und an den hotel eingängen
wird sogar der personalausweis bei der
rückgabe wieder desinfiziert in
barcelona merkt man sofort dass etwas
nicht stimmt wir sind hier jetzt gerade
auf einer der beliebtesten
aussichtsplattform barcelona tief oder
allerdings gerade von der polizei
geräumt und dafür war dass in so viele
leute hier oben waren alkohol getrunken
haben und dementsprechend auch ihre
masten nicht mehr aufraffen so kommt
ebenso gesundheit hier oben nicht mehr
gewährleistet werden
nicht alle halten sich an die regeln
wir haben hier 38 grad zu warm mit einer
maske kann man einfach immer ich hoffe
ich es kann doch nur schlecht zwar die
gleiche maske zu tragen
doch die meisten menschen in barcelona
halten sich an die masken pflicht sogar
beim joggen
ich fühle mich nicht sicher nein aber
immerhin trage ich dazu bei die dinge
besser zu machen
diese maske schützt mich nicht aber ich
schütze die anderen und ich glaube daran
dass mich die anderen auch schützen
worden ich versuche volle plätze zu
vermeiden ist es unsere eigene
verantwortung
auch in den restaurants und bars passen
die spanier auf die masken pflicht wird
sehr ernst genommen und ab mitternacht
ist alles geschlossen
wir haben barcelona hier als ein
risikogebiet erlebt in dem es sich nicht
wirklich nach risiko anfühlt die leute
tragen wirklich alle eine maske auf den
öffentlichen straßen klar sehen auch
manche die maske pflicht kritisch aber
dennoch halten sie sich daran auch hier
am flughafen tragen sich alle leute eine
maske und wird sehr darauf geachtet dass
die maske auch wirklich die nase und den
mund bedeckt damit gerade den
sicherheits stecken hinter uns da
mussten wir noch kein kroner test machen
und ob wir den jetzt noch machen müssen
bevor wir ins flugzeug steigen oder erst
in deutschland das werden uns jetzt mal
anschauen
diese bilder sind jetzt vor nur wenigen
stunden entstanden
unsere reporterin tiere auf der suche
nach dem corona test aber hier am quasi
lehrern flughafen barcelona ist nichts
zu finden
also ab ins flugzeug hier sitzen die
wenigen passagiere auseinander und alle
tragen eine maske
in wenigen minuten wird keira in
deutschland landen
ob sie einen corona test tatsächlich
machen muss das erfahren wir in kürze ja
und kira ortmann ist jetzt gelandet und
ist mehr live vom berliner schönefelder
flughafen zugeschaltet hallo hallo musst
du denn jetzt schon einen test machen
nein wir sind jetzt gerade aus dem
flugzeug ausgestiegen geworden war durch
eine schleuse hier zum ausdruck gebracht
das lag aber nur daran dass die das
sicherheitspersonal eine person gesucht
hat das hat also nichts mit beruf und
jetzt hier am flughafen angekommen am
ausgang angekommen trainiert schöner
dass wir dieses jahrhundert ist machen
soll jedoch ganz gut beschrieben wo man
sich erst anmelden soll und so weiter
aber von einer pflicht da steht hier
irgendwo nicht und es kontrolliert auch
keiner wir sind jetzt am ausgang wir
stehen schon draußen und könnten
theoretisch direkt nach hause fahren das
machen wir natürlich nicht wir machen
hier vielleicht ist es aber dass
kontrolliert feiern konnte denn auch mit
anderen leuten sprechen die mit dir im
flieger saßen wie sie das ganze finden
ja ja die leute sind alle sehr
verunsichert wir haben jetzt gerade auch
noch fehler gemacht aus dem volk das die
leute haben im flugzeug trotzdem aber
auch keinen abstand mehr gehalten als
der flieger gelandet ist wenn alle
aufgesprungen und haben
hoffer genommen alle haben derartige
fragen immer entsprechend habe man sich
schon recht sicher gefühlt aber stand
jetzt auch vor diesen schildern viele
menschen die sich eben informieren
wollten aber dass die personalwahl das
informiert das war leider nicht der fall